I read this book and I couldn't believe
that this man led this lifestyle and
still survived but didn't you in fact
actually talk to him during the making
of the film in some way wait he white
incessantly
so tell us who he was that mean we know
his story in the book but you just said
one interesting thing he he was truthful
yes to himself that's what I think I
appreciated most was that he you know to
him the book I think was a cautionary
tale of his time on Wall Street and
since you know since that time he's a
much different person and he's actually
depicted as we depict him at the end of
this movie of somebody that's going
around talking about the dangers of
greed and and trying to you know get
into the business sector with this with
you know some sort of moral foundation
kind of Tony Robbins of his time
exactly but his he was incredibly candid
in and and honest with me about what he
went through and a lot of times he would
talk about sections in the book and said
not only was it that bad I was ten times
worse and I'm gonna tell you why and and
I really appreciated that honesty
because I think you know from Marty's
perspective he wanted to have a little
bit of distance from that subject but I
needed to speak to him constantly just
to get you know the nuances in the
detail of of what these scenes were like
you have said that that the speeches
were some of the hardest stuff because
that's where you saw the art of
salesmanship you saw how much he
believed almost or did what he was
saying and it was almost messianic and
well you know I had been thinking about
the omen Terry went to wrote this
incredible screenplay really catered for
Marty and myself and I've been thinking
about these speeches for for almost six
years and and and you know mechanically
breaking them down but it wasn't really
until I was on that stage where it kind
of took on a life of its own
I I kind of felt closer to what Jordan
must have felt during that time period
where he almost created a cult for
himself and and and being consumed by
that adoration and and and the power of
you know being able to provide
amounts of wealth to this mass of people
that were worshipping him and when I got
on that stage it it kind of took on this
incredible life of its own and I kind of
felt like I was Bono or some rocks are
you know I knew even though I knew that
these the these you know actors were
paid to clap every single time I was
shouting at them you get this incessant
need to you know you know push them
forward and it almost became like this
you know Braveheart speech or cry for
battle except that was persuading them
to go out there and you know essentially
screw as many people over responsible